madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition du journal le feu
ravage le massif des alpilles dans les
bouches du rhône depuis hier soir la
situation reste préoccupante à l'heure
qu'il est le vent le relief du terrain
et l'épaisseur de la végétation rendent
très difficile le travail des pompiers
l'état va verser 105 milliards de francs
région entre 2000 et 2006 le
gouvernement réunis à arles pour un
comité d'aménagement du territoire
annonce trois priorités solidarité
emploi et environnement
le premier ministre belge décident la
fermeture de 300 élevages de porcs
supplémentaires la contamination à la
dioxine qui a déjà frappé les élevages
de poulets s'étend le temps des
festivals c'est le temps de la liberté
que ce soit à aix-en-provence ouailles
vignon les chorégraphes s'offrent
quelques audaces la danse se fait dans
la rue et l'opéra se laisse aller au hip
hop
c'est le premier grand feu de l'été
ils ravagent depuis hier soir le massif
des alpilles entre mouriès ses oreilles
plus de 1000 pompiers de plusieurs
départements sont sur place
dimon bardier d'eau continuent leur
intervention mais la situation ce soir
est préoccupante l' incendie qui
pourrait être d'origine criminelle n'a
pour l'instant pas fait de victime
sur place nous envoyés spéciaux yannick
aroussi michel com
c'est un peu le jeu du chat et de la
souris tout l'après-midi les reprises de
peu se sont multipliés le vent est
toujours violents des rafales à plus de
100 km alors qu'à la mi journée les
pompiers pensaient avoir le dessus
croyez avoir pitrel incendies les
flammes sont repartis à l'assaut de la
punaise
assez virulent
je pense pas qu'il va se calmer de
costco
en début d'après midi les habitants d'un
lotissement de mouriès ont dû quitter
leur maison
plein de fumée était décidément trop
proche on répondre avant première sur
pas trahi et c'est venu que doucement
doucement tout doucement très doucement
et puis il ya tout s'est embrasé d'un
seul coup nous a tous est battu et c'est
une catastrophe
pourtant là aucune maison n'a été touché
mais au cours de la nuit dernière deux
habitations avaient été dévastés par les
flammes et de mots sales ce matin avec
l'entrée en action des moyens aériens
l'ampleur de l'incendié avait fortement
diminué les pompiers exerçant une
surveillance très stricte des lisières
la chaleur le vent car sans ça va partir
comme ça qu'on est là le vent tout au
long de la nuit il a été le principal
adversaire des hommes au sol
river à cause de l'obscurité de l'appui
aérien
les pompiers ont lutté au corps à corps
avec un incendie parti peu avant la
tombée de la nuit aux environs de saint
rémy de provence
ben on attend on est en train de tout
temps limité et avec camions et pas
beaucoup d'eau partout les riverains
mettre la main à la pâte propose de
l'eau ont leur possible pour sauver leur
patrimoine prêts à toutes les
éventualités
le coeur gros ici ça vire et cuisine oui
la même maison
ce soir tous les habitants des alpilles
et craignent de revivre une nuit de feu
les reprises sont nombreuses sautes de
ballons en wallon et ce dans toutes les
directions
1600 hectares de forêt ont été brûlés et
le mistral devraient continuer à
souffler dans les prochaines heures
les 1000 pompiers sont toujours sur le
qui vive et les moyens aériens vont
faire le maximum avant la tombée de la
nuit
le dispositif de secours et de lutte
contre l' incendie mise en place
mobilise hommes et matériel de plusieurs
départements dans les communes menacées
plusieurs évacuations notamment celle de
campeur ont eu lieu car inkomazi pascal
pons dans la salle des fêtes de mouriès
à quelques kilomètres des baux de
provence 150 personnes ont trouvé refuge
la nuit dernière évacuées d'un camping
voisin
c'était notre première nuit en france et
nous avons été accueillis alors notre
première des choses à raconter tout ça
est que nous avons passé une nuit
blanche
nuit blanche et journée agitée pour les
pompiers venus de quinze départements
pour nous un honneur au poste de
commandement mobile ils sont à peine 10
à suivre la progression du feu sans
relâche par téléphone et par radio qu'il
a voilà
goyer à l'autre bout de la radio mille
hommes prêts à sauter dans leurs
véhicules pour maîtriser les nouveaux
départs de feu
la zone est vaste près de 2000 hectares
116 survolé par une dizaine de canadair
c'est un point qui monte au niveau du
alors mais qui parle pas de tous les
côtés c'est vrai que c'est assez
difficile avec une teinture si on arrive
à avoir des petites sautes de feu comme
énorme intérêt à deux pas de celui des
pompiers le poste de commandement des
gendarmes les brigades de recherche
d'art les deux salons examine les quatre
départs de feu de la nuit dernière des
feux apparemment d'origine criminelle et
délits sont sont d'une facilité et d'une
criminalité forte qu'ils doivent être
évidemment publie avec la plus grande
sévérité des colonnes de renforts venus
de plusieurs départements sont attendus
ce soir dans les alpilles
avec nous le lieutenant-colonel le
robert bardot monsieur vous dirigez
les opérations et les sapeurs pompiers
des bouches du rhône vous vous rentrez
du feu là vous y étiez prêts et près des
flammes ya quelques instants où en est
la situation aujourd'hui tels que vous
avez pu l'apprécier
oui tout d'abord je suis le directeur
adjoint du service incendie est bon nous
avons une situation qui a évolué dans le
courant de l'après midi du fait de l'art
en force du vent je pense que nous
devons avoir parcouru environ
demi-hectare aujourd'hui avec un
dispositif un moyen qui est énorme
puisqu'il y avait mille hommes sur le
terrain pour 260 et 280 véhicules plus
une dizaine d'avions bombardiers d'eau à
tour de rôle que comment se présente la
situation pour les heures qui viennent
et pour les heures qui viennent nous
allons amorcer la nuit alors pour nous
c'est plutôt défavorable au sens que la
visibilité est mauvaise et surtout nous
allons perdre l'aide de des moyens
aériens
je pense que la première partie de la
nuit jusqu'à minuit devrait continuer à
bien à peu près sur le même rythme mais
pour avoir pris les prévisions météo aux
environs de deux heures du matin on
devrait avoir une petite accalmie du
vent qui devrait ensuite
se maintenir jusqu'à demain dans la
matinée alors bon c'est on va utiliser
cette accalmie pour essayer de fixer
encore les lisières qui sont qui sont
violentes
est ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle qu'il ya des reprises du feu ou
ce que le feu est circonscrit un
périmètre donné dans le feu n'est pas
circonscrit nous avions
fixer le feu dans le fin de matinée
parce que le vent avait un tant soit peu
faibli mais le renforcement du vent a
fait que de nombreuses rizières sur un
feu qui est très important de nombreux
tunisiens sont de nouveau active
donc c'est un feu qui est en propagation
il est par propagation totalement libre
parce que c'est de ce sont des petits
îlotage à certains endroits pour des
cultures et des zones de végétation plus
dense de pinèdes et de garrigue
mais c'est un feu qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas assez parce qu'il merci
colonel par ailleurs selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète ce feu serait
d'origine douteuse donc peut-être
d'origine criminelle
et puis l'instant on apprend que
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
quitté leur logement aux angles c'est
dans le gard près de villeneuve les
avignon
là aussi après le départ d'un important
incendie en corse également on a
constaté de nombreux départs de feux
notamment dans le sud est de l'île le
vent violent là non plus n'a pas
facilité les interventions des pompiers
à corte par exemple 250 hectares ont été
détruits
la suite de l'actualité en belgique et
la contamination par la dioxine des
élevages de viande n'a pas fini de
produire ses effets les autorités belges
ont été contraintes dans la journée de
fermer 300 élevages de porcs
supplémentaires alors que près de 800
sont déjà sous séquestre au total suite
à cette contamination se sont entre 60
et 80 mille tonnes de viande qui devront
être détruites pour le nouveau
gouvernement belge un premier dossier
difficile
yann france pour francis les riques
éleveurs d'efforts en belgique
cette journée a commencé par un
véritable coup de massue
lui qui croyait que la crise de la
dioxine et est passé lui qui attendait d
indemnisation de l'état a appris ce
matin que rien n'était fini et que la
situation était bien plus grave que
prévu une catastrophe pour ce petit
éleveurs indépendants
pour une catastrophe et c'est vraiment
il faudra liquider les les ports
autrement en cours à la faillite
car dès ce matin au cours d'une réunion
exceptionnelle le gouvernement belge a
décidé de placer de nouveaux élevages
sous séquestre nous avons décidé de
mettre sous séquestre 300 firmes
supplémentaire parce que le monitoring
nous a permis de détecter un problème
supplémentaire
le monitoring c'est à dire les contrôles
les analyses effectués pour déceler des
traces de dioxine et d'après les
premiers résultats des tests la période
de contamination a été plus longue que
prévu
l'origine de la crise elle reste la même
d'après le gouvernement
des huiles de friture mélangés à des
huiles industrielles souvent toxiques
ont été livrés à la société vers qu est
ce qui les transforme en grèce graisses
destinées à l'alimentation animale des
graisses qu'on retrouve ensuite dans des
centaines d'élevage impossible de
connaître leur nombre exact
mais le gouvernement des comptes ce soir
près de 800 pour plus de sécurité
il pourrait donc décider de retirer dans
les prochaines heures toute la viande
porcine et ses produits dérivés des
supermarchés comme ce fut le cas il ya
quelques semaines dans l'actualité
politique un contrat de plan est signée
entre l'état et la région dans le cadre
de l'aménagement du territoire
symboliquement c'est arles en région
donc que lionel jospin a réuni son
gouvernement pour annoncer que 105
milliards de francs irait aux régions
entre 2000 et 2006 solidarité emploi et
environnement sont les priorités
réaffirmée par le premier ministre sur
place alban nicosie
jacques gregor qui ont un jour figurer
le savent bien pour réaliser une belle
photo de groupe
nominé il monte un peu de discipline
donc voilà l'image que le gouvernement
voulait donner une famille solidaire où
chacun joue fort le matin presque tous
réunis ont procédé aux derniers
arbitrages sur les contrats de plan 2000
2006 avec un maître mot rééquilibrage
ainsi les régions réputées rick je ne
seront plus oublier provence côte d'azur
aquitaine centre ile de france pays de
loire et rhône alpes en sombre sur cette
carte voient leur dotation croître
sensiblement
nous avons marqué de grandes inflexion
dans la méthode nous avons banni les
promesses inconsidérées et irréaliste
dans les contenus nous avons donné la
priorité au rééquilibrage entre les
grands secteurs d'investissement ainsi
sur les 105 milliards de dotation
globale les transports en aurons 30 mai
la priorité ira au rayo fluvial 16
milliards pour l'éducation et un effort
conséquent sur la politique de la ville
autre grande gagnante
dominique voynet son concept de
développement durable est officiellement
consacré le développement durable c'est
pas nous emmène pas c'était le souci
d'évaluer l'impact des missions
publiques à tous les domaines mais pour
je
décidément à l'aise en monsieur loyal
lionel jospin a si les ministres dans un
ordre très précis et dominique voynet à
côté de lui mais il paraît au moins
prématuré d'y voir message politique
lionel jospin par ailleurs annoncé que
l'état consacrerait en plus de cette
enveloppe 15 milliards de francs des
projets régionaux qui devrait être
discuté d'ici à janvier dans le cadre
notamment d'équipement d'importance
nationale désensabler le
mont-saint-michel contrat de plan
construire des autoroutes ou développer
le tourisme sur la loire contrat de plan
voilà deux exemples de l'utilité de
cette collaboration institutionnelle
entre l'état et les régions il en est
d'autres alès le vigan dans le gard
l'argent de l'état utilisée par la
région sert en priorité l'emploi dans
une zone où le taux de chômage est deux
fois plus important que la moyenne
nationale
laurent bailly jean yves blanc la piste
de karting est flambant neuf est
totalement inattendu sur ces 90 hectares
aux portes d'alès de cette friche
industrielle sortent peu à peu des
bâtiments financés par la région
l'europe et surtout par l'état pour que
ce projet prenne corps pour attirer ici
une vingtaine d'entreprises mécanique et
créer 500 emplois
le maire d'alès paie de sa personne la
cour d' aujourd'hui il obtient 50
millions supplémentaires après quatre
ans d'efforts on a l'impression que dix
d'entre eux mais la parisienne riz
perçoit perçoit très mal ces petites
infrastructures qui se créent dans des
villes vous dépassez un moyen comme un
autre comme quantité négligeable
suivraient que dans l'agent le coup
voyez ici on n'aura pas ni fournir aux
noms qui viennent macrez famille bouzid
à moi de vous créer plusieurs milliers
d'emplois en tout dans ce bassin minier
sinistrés c'est en tout cas la priorité
de ce contrat ce plan ici il y avait un
temps travaillé dix sept mille mine
aujourd'hui à alès le taux de chômage
dépasse 20 % la dernière mine de charbon
n'emploie plus que 200 personnes et elle
doit fermer l'an prochain les mineurs
eux ne croient guère aux efforts engagés
pour diversifier l'activité économique
et on conversion industrielle d'alès
c'est quelque chose très aléatoire
puisque jusqu'à présent tout ce qui nous
a été proposée depuis les premières
fermetures de mines en matière de
reconversion
il ya très très peu de choses qui me
tenait au pour beaucoup d'entreprises de
son menu mais on ferme et très
rapidement la zone industrielle oasis
subventions prêts immobiliers
exonérations diverses
ici tout est fait pour séduire les
entreprises le grand père de grégory
travaillaient dans la mine lui après
avoir pointé à l'anpe s'est fait
embaucher ici dès que les premiers
bâtiments sont sortis de terre le fip le
ca s'est créée ces des bâtiments qui
appartiennent à la mairie donc qui sont
loués beaucoup moins cher pour les
entreprises qui permet de lancer
d'entrée c'est grâce à ça que vous avez
trouvé un emploi vous oui les emplois
nous vous serons île durable c'est toute
la question
les alésiens welt y croire mais demande
à voir il ya des efforts mais je pense
qu'il manquait des forces et des
ressources financières et
gérer le mal bu du vin pour les stars
j'espère que ça va pour aller de l'avant
on va par exemple prolonger cette route
deux fois deux voies entre alès et nîmes
l'état apporte aujourd'hui 300 millions
de francs pour moderniser les tronçons
désuet de cette nationale une mesure
concrète autant qu'un symbole pour
contribuer à désenclaver alès le vigan
130 mille habitants le parent pauvre des
cévennes à strasbourg parlement européen
des regroupements se font c'est ainsi
que les neuf députés de l'alliance
nationale italienne la formation
héritière du mouvement néofasciste msi
ont rejoint le groupe union pour
l'europe des nations qui comprend
notamment les 13 eurodéputés français
élus sur la liste conduite par monsieur
pasqua et de villiers désormais la
droite souverainiste compte donc que 30
membres et forment un groupe ce qui lui
donne des facilités matérielles
secrétaire aux voitures et plus de force
d'intervention
le président chirac est arrivé tout à
l'heure au nigeria troisième étape de
son voyage africain et première visite
d'un président français dans ce pays
anglophone le plus peuplé d'afrique
il compte 100 millions d'habitants le
pouvoir y ait été remis au civil il y a
juste un mois après plus de 15 ans de
régime militaire
le président français arrivé du togo la
visite était délicate dans le rythme du
togo il y à un volumineux dossier droits
de l'homme instruits par amnesty
international
jacques chirac a estimé que
l'organisation internationale avait pu
être manipulée quand elle a dénoncé des
massacres commis en 1998 cela dit il
s'est également dit convaincu que le
président eyadéma au pouvoir depuis 1967
ne briguerait pas un nouveau mandat en
2003 le bilan de cette visite sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux eric monier jean
cornu l'amitié qui lie les présidents
chirac et iliad est marrant mais
paradoxalement cette étape périlleuse
au sein même de l'exécutif français
beaucoup étaient réticents voire rétifs
à ce séjour de 24 heures à lomé très
longtemps incertain la crainte sans
doute que des propos des images lyriques
l'opposition togolaise
une opposition qui vient à peine
d'accepter de s'asseoir à une table de
négociations pour tenter de dénouer la
crise qui gangrène et ruinent le pays
depuis huit ans et puis on s'était pris
à rêver qu'une telle visite créer ici un
électrochoc
las ce matin en recevant l'opposition le
président français n'a pu que constater
l'absence du plus virulent des opposants
eyadema gilchrist olympio et les
facilitateurs
les médiateurs internationaux ne pouvait
que regretter cette absence lui ai
téléphoné encore hier soir et ce matin
pour lui dire qu'il serait le bienvenu
il a décidé de ne pas venir c'est un
choix personnel sur lequel je ne ferai
pas de commentaire enfin de miracle mais
un espoir dans son point de presse cet
après midi jacques chirac s'est dit
encore optimiste la médiation
internationale court jusqu'au 30 juillet
mais on sentait poindre son impatience
pour mettre en garde tous les acteurs
politiques togolais il ne se contentait
plus du seul poids de la france
la lassitude que l'on ressent
aujourd'hui je les grands partenaires
ceux qui doivent être les grands
partenaires du togo c'est de lassitude
conduite à l'indifférence c'est un
processus très dangereux et qui risquent
petit à petit de déraper vers la
recherche de solutions strictement
interne c'est-à-dire vers la violence
le voyage coup de poker de jacques
chirac n'a pas donné les effets
escomptés
voilà bien une nouvelle preuve que la
france seule la plus le pouvoir de
régler les problèmes même
dans son ancien pré carré africain et
puis au maroc hassan ii était
hospitalisé à rabat selon la maison
royale il souffre d'une pneumopathie
aiguë qui nécessite une surveillance
cardio-respiratoire la contestation
continue en serbie une centaine de
réservistes de l'armée ont coupé la
circulation jeudi dans le centre ville
de nietzsche pour réclamer le paiement
de leurs sols de ceux ci ont été
rejoints et encouragé par des passants
et des automobilistes qui ont hué
slobodan milosevic
pendant ce temps celui ci comme si de
rien n'était a visité le quartier
général de l'armée à belgrade
affirmant que celle ci avait acquis une
solide expérience face à l'otan et
qu'elles seraient modernisées et mieux
dotées technologiquement
dans le même temps le général commandant
la troisième armée qui était déployée au
kosovo réaffirma soutien sans réserve à
slobodan milosevic et affirme par
ailleurs que si c'est nécessaire il
enverra l'armée au kosovo pour rétablir
l'ordre
les familles kennedy et 17 ont rendu
hommage à new york à l'occasion d'une
messe célébrée dans l'intimité à john
fitzgerald kennedy junior son épouse et
sa belle soeur 300 personnes étaient
invitées les clinton assistaient à cette
cérémonie
france 2 sur place parce qu'elle nous
c'est bon le président était à l'heure
comme les autres invités bill clinton ne
s'est pas approchée de l'unique caméras
autorisés à filmer l'entrée de l'église
saint-thomas cement juste avant lui
plusieurs membres de la famille 17 et
tous les kennedy avait pris place dans
l'église
arnold schwarzenegger fait partie du
clan il a épousé maria shriver une
cousine de john-john la police à fixer
le périmètre de sécurité à plus de deux
kilomètres à la ronde
dès 5 heures du matin pas question de
voir la cérémonie
tout au plus sait-on que c'est ted
kennedy le sénateur qui prononce
l'oraison funèbre de son neveu les
badauds échaudé par les avertissements
des médias sont moins nombreux que prévu
mais les vrais fans eux ont fait le
déplacement
car elle ne se fait pas prier pour
assister son poème il évoque la promesse
tenue du rêve américain
la tragédie les larmes et fait de jon
une merveille du monde hier dans un
quartier moins chic de manhattan
la commémoration était publique
organisée par la communauté américano
irlandaise
bref d'un bout à l'autre de new york
chacun aura pu honorer les défunts mais
pas au même endroit ni aucun instant
asaint au mas morts la cérémonie s'est
terminée il y à une heure et demie
environ
les deux familles auront tout fait pour
garder pour elles leur émotion
en ce moment même les 250 invités sont
réunis au très chic couvent du
sacré-coeur là où étudier carolyn
bessette lorsqu'elle était enfant
vingt-quatre heures après les adieux du
petit peuple de new york
c'est au tour de la jet set de dire au
revoir dignement à ses enfants
finalement finalement après deux reports
les deux mille tonnes de la navette
columbia records de poids se sont
envolés la nuit dernière du centre
spatial kennedy en floride
l'histoire voudra retenir que c'est la
première fois qu'une femme est
commandant de bord
l'objectif de cette mission qui inclut
également le français tony était de
mettre sur orbite un satellite
observatoire de rayons x celui ci
devrait donner pendant cinq ans des
renseignements importants sur les trous
noirs par exemple où les collisions
entre galaxies de même que des
informations sur les explosions des
toiles en fin de vie pour les
spécialistes de la nasa de quoi changer
notre façon de penser l'univers fait
divers l'évêque de bayeux dans le
calvados mise en cause par un avocat
pour non dénonciation de viol dans une
affaire concernant un prêtre de son
diocèse estime que ces accusations sont
infondées
il s'appuie et il avance le secret de la
confession
patrick fandio fabrice hausse c'est un
homme blessé dix est proche
monseigneur pierre pican mise en cause
pour non dénonciation de viol sur
mineure ne souhaitait pas vraiment
parler aux médias cet après-midi ce qui
devait donc être une conférence de
presse s'est transformé en une
déclaration lue à la presse aussi bref
que laconique les accusations qui sont
portées contre moi dans des conditions
étonnantes à travers les médias suite au
dépôt de cette plainte
je tiens à réaffirmer avec clarté
qu'elle ne repose sur aucune réalité et
sont infondées infondées dit le prélat
la plainte déposée hier par l'avocat des
victimes 15 garçons dont le plus jeune
avait à peine six ans et qui aurait subi
les abus sexuels de cet homme
l'abbé brisset le prêtre a été arrêté en
septembre 98 mais pour ces familles
monseigneur piquant connaissait ses
actes pédophiles dès 1997 au lieu de les
dénoncer
l'évêque n'aurait fait que muter le
prêtre dans une autre paroisse
les mesures qu aurait dû prendre
lévesque s'est d'abord en tant que
citoyen avertir le procureur de la
république et faire en sorte que les
veys et que le curé ne soit plus en
relation avec les adolescents or il n'a
muté dans une autre paroisse et il a
pris le risque que le curé re comme
prêtèrent ces actes défendre l'intérêt
des victimes ou préserver le secret de
la confession pour l'église le choix
n'est pas simple entre deux notions
inscrite dans la loi divine et dans le
code pénal
dénoncer et donc une obligation mais il
se trouve que cette obligation par les
textes du code pénal ne vise pas ce qui
dans le cadre de leur métier de leur
charge de leur mission ont pour
obligation de respecter le secret
professionnel dans le cadre des
confidences qu'il reçoit quant à l'abbé
brice et écroué pour viol
il est détenu à la maison d'arrêt de
caen en attendant d'être fixé sur son
éventuel procès devant les assises du
calvados
à rennes la reconstruction du parlement
de bretagne détruit par un incendie en
février 1994 s'achève la façade
restaurée vient d'être dévoilée et ce
matin les clés ont été remises aux
magistrats de la cour d'appel qui
devrait se réinstaller au mois d'octobre
dans les lieux olivier piou michel hiver
une remise solennelle de clés pour les
magistrats de la cour d'appel de rennes
mais une clé tout symbolique puisque la
cour ne réintégrera vraiment les lieux
qu'en octobre
et pourtant cinq ans et demi après le
tragique incendie de février 94
le palais du parlement renaît de ses
cendres au terme de ce qui fut plus
qu'une restauration une véritable
reconstruction qui s'achèvera d'ailleurs
que dans deux ou trois ans à la fin de
l'année 2002 2003
danser dans ces eaux là et bien
l'ensemble du parlement a retrouvé sa
splendeur
il aura fallu presque dix ans pour pour
l'aveyron de 700 heures presque dix ans
pour lui rendre
y compris le délai d études mais lors de
sa construction il a fallu plus de vingt
ans déjà certaines salles ont retrouvé
leur lustre d'antan avec lambris très
grand siècle et peintures restaurées au
passage 700 mètres carrés
supplémentaires ont été créés et
accessoirement le parlement de bretagne
devient le premier palais du xviie
entièrement câblé un petit coup de pouce
peut-être ou lenteur de la justice il
est clair que l'ensemble de ces
améliorations est de nature à apporter
une plus grande rapidité et surtout à
faciliter le travail de chacun et donc
alors permettre de répondre dans de
meilleures conditions et en effet plus
rapidement le parlement reconstruit
restera à le faire vivre et le fait
revoir car après l'impact médiatique de
l' incendie et des travaux il paraît
inconcevable que le public n'ait pas sa
part du monument retrouver les
magistrats ont donc mis sur pied une
association pour animer le parlement des
concerts des expositions dans des salles
d'audience du jamais vu pour une cour
d'appel tour de france et l'italien
monde uni qui a enlevé la 18ème étape à
poitiers il a battu le français jean
cyril robin de trois secondes
ceci après une échappée lancée à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de l'arrivée
l'américain armstrong conserve bien sûr
son maillot jaune demain contre la
montre toujours à poitiers avant les
champs elysées dimanche le 18 octobre à
auckland en nouvelle zélande partir à la
coupe de l'america l'équipage français
du défi sixième sens est actuellement en
entraînement à lorient sixième sens et
le 3 la troisième génération du défi
français après le baron bich qui
souvenez-vous dans les années 70 puis
marc pajot cette fois petite équipe
petit budget mais bien sûr important
travail collectif christophe duchiron
frédérick basile
et comme un décor deuxième guerre
mondiale l'ancienne base des sous-marins
de lorient
indestructible édifice déserté par les
militaires depuis peu le défi français
de la coupe de l'america en a fait son
camp d'entraînement
pour les hommes d'équipage chaque jour
qui commence s'annonce comme le jour le
plus long
7h du matin à l'intérieur d'une grande
tente blanche
la salle de gym à côté sous la même
tente la voilerie casper le maître
voilier s'est couché tard comme
d'habitude et s'est levé tôt
le travail ne manque pas et si personne
ne ménagent sa peine avec 54 millions de
francs les français sont les champions
du monde du plus petit budget de la
coupe c'est par exemple six fois moins
que les italiens la philosophie du défi
c'est clairement d'être un tout petit
peu décalé par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
par le passé vers la couronne et les cas
d'essayer de faire beaucoup avec peu
d'argent et d'aller droit au but pour
but lorsqu on attend seul bateau parce
qu'on est une petite équipe on n'a pas
le temps c'est clair de faire beaucoup
de développements sur le sur ce type de
bateau
donc on est obligé d'aller à l'essentiel
de se concentrer sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir un bon bateau
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre la phase
finale des éliminatoires 24 mètres
cinquante de long 1 maru 2 32 m très
étroits comme une lame qui fait en lots
un prototype conçu par cet expert une
oeuvre collective qui rompt avec la
démarche solitaire et park autocratique
du passé chaque après midi depuis la mi
juin
ces jeunes s'entraînent à bord mais
lundi soir là on a des bonnes sensations
on a des bonnes sensations parce que la
vitesse est très stable parce que le
bateau est sain il est bien né il n'y a
pas de surprise par rapport à tout ce
qui était tout ce qui est issu de calcul
se confirme à l'échelle 1 donc ça c'est
tout c'est toujours bon signe
bon il faut faire confiance aux autres
défis pour mettre aussi au point des
machines
il est 23 heures mais il ya encore de la
lumière
l'après midi ils naviguaient le soir ils
s'occupent des voiles et c'est ainsi
pour chaque membre de l'équipage
sortie en mer travail à terre l'homme à
tout faire
et demain on recommence les gens du défi
sixième sens non pas la folie des
grandeurs ils sont modestes pragmatique
et ambitieux
départ donc au mois d'octobre une
promenade maintenant à aix en provence
et avignon à l'occasion des festivals de
l'été
dans le premier cas il s'agit d'art
lyrique dans le second de théâtre
pourtant à chaque fois ce sont des
chorégraphes qui s'élance sur des
chemins de traverse
daniel wolfromm michel levasseur il a
l'air d'un passant ordinaire
justement son talent de se couler dans
le paysage avec son partenaire
mine de rien le célèbre cours mirabeau à
aix en provence et son trafic font leurs
affaires
il dit intervient presque sans déranger
plus qu'un simple décor tout ce qui
passe à l'improviste se transformer en
acteur involontaire de leurs
chorégraphies
le couple improvise dans les rues de la
ville
la spontanéité fait la force de leurs
balais le public d'abord intrigué
comprend vite qu'il a à faire à des
danseurs professionnels certaine
harmonie entre l'environnement non je
faisais super bravo
on devrait en voir plus souvent
reprendre en même temps mais que tous
les trajets du public autour avec son
ressemblant l'instant et c'est qu'on
reçoit des gens se conçoit des espaces
qu'on reçoit des objets ce qu'on reçoit
du les mouvements de tous les mouvements
alors démonstration urbaine va durer une
vingtaine de minutes
c'est une des deux chorégraphies de rue
retenu officiellement cet été par le
festival d'aix-en-provence
avignon le cadre le jardin clos d'un
lycée est plus traditionnel mais le
procédé lui l'est beaucoup moins
accompagné par ce troublant
percussionniste et sous la conduite
d'une star du hip hop
farid berki un danseur étoile de l'opéra
de paris kader belarbi pour ce curieux
mélange de classique et de traitement
là ce sont les objets symboles de la
ville qui sont amenés sur scène y est
comme à aix en provence cette
chorégraphie et chartres également à
toutes les conventions
terminons avec noah jeune chanteuse
israélienne elle a 30 ans elle était
hier soir en concert à deux villes elle
s'apprête à sortir un nouvel album
qu'elle ira enregistré en bretagne
sophie mais elle jacques girard elle est
devenue une artiste engagée presque
malgré elle
parce que comme aldi lorsqu'on est juive
israélienne laïque et chanteuse
on n'a pas le choix mais de sa lutte
pour la paix de son soutien et août
barak
elle ne glisse dans ce texte que les
évocations et comprenne qui pourra
pour moi une chanson doit pas être
utilisée comme une tribune
si j'ai des opinions je préfère les
cachets dans mes chansons si les gens
choisissent ce que je veux dire bon
sinon s'il y trouve autre chose tant
mieux
avec un lit
aliens cadalen
elle parle en revanche plus facilement
des contradictions qui la tourmente
cette part d'innocence qu'elle cherche à
préserver face à la nécessité d'avoir
l'air forte
garneau a c'est cela un melting-pot à
elle toute seule
né en israël d'une famille originaire du
yémen éducation américaine à la dure
école du bronx on la prenait pour une
portoricaine avant de retourner vivre il
ya dix ans
tout ça fait une drôle de cuisine dit
elle mais au moins j'espère qu'elles
abondent
tous les compliments sont moins de ses
chansons elle aimerait qu'on retienne
une émotion un sentiment l'envi de rire
de danse et même de pleurer
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous en
rappelle les deux principaux titres le
feu ravage toujours le massif des
alpilles dans les bouches du rhône deux
mille hectares ont été détruits
la situation reste préoccupante à
l'heure qu'il est le vent qui continuent
de souffler le relief du terrain et
l'épaisseur de la végétation rendre plus
difficile le travail des pompiers
l'état va verser 105 milliards de francs
en régions entre 2000 et 2006 le
gouvernement réunit arles pour un comité
d'aménagement du territoire et lionel
jospin réaffirme trois priorités
solidarité emploi et environnement
et puis dans un instant la météo
d'isabel martinez suivi du point route
de valérie maurice 20h50 la série
urgences trois numéros l'édition de la
nuit ce sera m mettez à demain 13h
excellente soirée à tous sur france 2